irina yesterday
two days ago was the kind of day that
you say
how did i possibly make such a move
two days later you get to take down one
of your big rivals in a very good game
you're first of all what did you do
right after the game round four game
where you blended a piece against
carissa yeah that's a good question
maurice you want me to reveal all my
secrets
all of them just what happened now what
do you do when you play such an
embarrassing game you know it just left
you so empty you know of course i was
you know i mean i thought my position
actually was acceptable at that point i
mean okay later on i saw the computer
still preferred white in this end game
but like my personal feeling was like
the worst was behind me and when i had
played that move bishop e4 and she
played bishop f1 and i got a little
careless you know and just completely as
soon as i made my move i was like oh
there's just double attack you know the
rook is moving back
um so it's it's quite uh it's quite a
pity when you lose a game like that
because it just feels like such a sudden
end you know like the game could have
been going on and on and like nothing
terrible was happening when you
blundered the piece so of course i was
not you know feeling good about that i
was pretty dejected it was you know um
so what did i do well um i think i did a
few good things over the last couple of
days i went to church on saturday and on
sunday and that was the one good thing
about losing to carissa so quickly is
that i got to make the church service on
saturday evening okay and your
perspective shifted over the live over
those two services yeah of course i mean
you know you start you start to feel
better and uh you know i had um you know
i had some support from some um some
people online and you know i realized
it's like okay it was only four rounds i
mean of course two out of four is not a
great score
but you can still there's so many rounds
that you can still work to catch up
and um so it's just a new new tournament
starting i felt better also i think i
got more used to playing with the mask
on you know i wasn't walking around in
the patio for all of the game like i've
been doing before because i just kind
and i realized it's like well you know
i'm not really thinking on my opponent's
move because i'm just trying to get some
fresh air outside
but now i kind of got used to it and i
stayed at the board today and um and
yeah today's game was pretty clean were
you surprised when she plays queen takes
on b2 yes i was surprised maurice i
would not have taken that pawn i would
have been so scared with those doubled
pawns in front of my king so i really i
really wasn't expecting her to do that i
mean i don't know if it's like losing
but it's just very like uncomfortable
position to play right uh even the
president of the pawn groupers club
yasser cerewon said no no no no not a
pawn
he would take right now allowing this
position and you just got an
overwhelming position
very quickly you did get a great game uh
but christian carrillo
spotted a fantastic tactical opportunity
for you uh we'd like to point out right
here yeah you had a move that
may have sealed the deal even quicker
okay oh 96
well maddie 96 is not bad queen's
actually h8 yeah the queen but queen g6
might have been oh wow more of
a killer blow as you would instantly go
into a winning end game with this move
wow um okay so pawn takes 96
the problem is she must lose d5 yeah by
force
interesting you know i have to say queen
sacrifices even when there's simple ones
like this they're so hard to think of in
the first place i've often found that
it's like the hardest move to even
notice that's very cute um you know what
i was looking at here is i was looking
at this move knight b3
and i thought at first this was quite a
decent move and you know the idea is i'm
not letting her take on d4 then i think
maybe she'll just sack on e3 you know
bishop takes e3 f takes e3 queen e5 now
she's threatening f5 trapping my bishop
so if i move it back she takes on e3
there's some kind of like bishop h3 all
the time my pieces are completely on the
queen side and so i didn't want to um
you know didn't want to give her any
chances like that so yeah that was one
line i noticed that could be promised
maybe looking for too many chances for
her instead of for yourself
in the end you ended up winning the game
here she couldn't tolerate this weakness
all that time although she looked like
she was trying to get some play but she
let your queen and rook get to the other
side and you were able to finish it off
looks like at least a rook in the offing
all right you made a win you're a plus
one certainly not 50 anymore
and uh carissa looks like she's in big
trouble
in her game
and a draw looks likely in the other
game as well
your chances about coming back your
feelings about coming back in this one
yeah i think the tournament just is
gonna go it's gonna be wide open now you
know so i feel pretty good um
i mean the most important thing is to
start playing well right that's really
all it is i mean there's so there's a
lot of rounds that you can
kind of do your work catching up in so i
mean how many rounds still six more it's
a lot you know what i thought about
actually um there were some years ago i
had a situation two rounds before the
tournament was a point behind anna and
so i had just two rounds to make up that
one point disadvantage i had to play her
directly and that's where i got to uh
make it up that was a really big game um
so i thought well you know where i am
now a point out of the lead after four
rounds you still got you know seven
rounds left to play it's really not as
bad as that situation was so that helps
me put in perspective you said a line to
me before i let you go that i have used
even
frequently in my talks
where you said celebrate your losses
yeah something that you heard and and
learned from someone else somebody wise
yeah
can you say you celebrated this last
loss
in any way against carissa i really
didn't no no i didn't celebrate it was
good that i didn't fall apart it was
good that i kind of like you know just
um was able to put it behind me
yeah well if you win this tournament
you'll celebrate the fact that you were
able to do that indeed but still a long
way as you said congrats on your victory
good luck in the rest of the day thank
you murrays
we need some of that thickness
who and who on earth instilled that
thought in your mind let me take that
seed and pull it out by its roots don't
celebrate your loss celebrate your whims
no i think it's a great point we can
argue it for a while but i
it's such a great point the thing is
if you if you
if you lose a game
right if you lose a game if you let that
loss stay in your system without being
able to figure out how to get it out
then it could carry over into the next
game into the next game into the next
game
so
you need to figure out what you learned
from that game what did that game teach
you what are the lessons that you got
from any individual occurrence in your
entire life something that any mistake
you make is an opportunity to learn so
you need to take that mistake and not
punish yourself over it because we all
make mistakes so instead of punishing
yourself saying how stupid you are what
an idiot i am i need to make a draw the
next round you say thank you very much
for the lesson i got the lesson i
learned from it i'm going to be stronger
i didn't die from it i'm going to be
stronger i'm going to play
better from this moment so it's a chance
it's an opportunity to grow i think most
of us just have a knee-jerk reaction
where we lose and we say
that was terrible and what happens next
you get another bagel and another bagel
and you keep losing
i think it's